twitter's right now worth what 40 some
billion dollars can you pull out what
twitter's worth today should i put this
on twitter today
if you can't get it the rounds are 100
million
uh if you can get in and there's not a
lot of people that are sitting on 100
million dollars of cash that's the
challenge market cap 38 billion okay
here's what i'll tell you
twitter
ran by elon musk will be a trillion
dollar company within three to five
years and that's the latest
which means and by the way this is my
opinion
okay this is if you do it you lose money
that's your risk this is my opinion
i think this is a trillion dollar
company
um i think that 40 goes to a trillion
that's 25 x you put a million bucks
you're gonna make 25 you put 10 million
bucks you're gonna make 250. you put 100
grand it's gonna be two and a half
million dollar investment
if google's worth the trillion if
amazon's worth two if you know i think
apple's worth three whatever the number
is this is gonna be a trillion dollar
company because the people that ran
twitter they don't know how to make
money and elon knows how to make money